Speaker 1: Let's instead go to is it Lincoln
from Boston or Boston? From Lincoln? It really
could be either.
Speaker 4: It is
Lincoln from Boston.
Speaker 1: Lincoln
from Boston. Welcome to the program.
Speaker 4: It's great to be here. I wanted
to ask you about the 2024 election.
Speaker 1: Lincoln,
are you originally from Boston?
Speaker 4: I was born in Massachusetts,
about 25 minutes south of Boston. But yes.
Speaker 1: Interesting, because I detected
a very slight like almost
like a Canadian accent there.
Speaker 4: No Canadian here. Okay.
Speaker 1: I mean, it wouldn't be an insult,
by the way. And Canada is a beautiful
place, but. All right. Go on, Lincoln.
Speaker 4: Well, so it is my understanding that in
2020, when Joe Biden and the Democratic Party won
the presidential election, a lot of that was due
to events transpiring that year. Namely, COVID,
of course, and the George Floyd protests.
And I'm worried. In 2024. Unfortunately,
it's awful to say this, but if there isn't major
events like that that take place, I'm worried the
Democratic Party won't have that fuel to to win.
Speaker 1: So I don't know that I necessarily
agree with the premise as far as the George
Floyd protests. I don't know how big of a
factor the George Floyd protests were in Biden's
win. I do think Trump's mishandling of COVID was
100% a factor in Joe Biden's win. But
I generally agree with your conclusion,
which is you're worried about Biden's ability
to win in 24. And here's my view on that.
It's much. How can I say this? You're at an
advantage in terms of how you can campaign
if you're not currently in power. And so even
though we know that Trump accomplished nothing of
value while he was president, we know that Trump
made all sorts of promises that he could never
possibly keep. We know all these things, right?
But the fact that Joe Biden has been in power and
if Trump is the nominee, he will have been out of
power. Or if Ron DeSantis is the nominee, he will
never have been president. They can attack Biden
in a particular way that you can't when you're
the person in charge. I think it's a benefit to
whoever is the eventual Republican nominee. And
I have significant concerns about whether Biden
would win that election. I don't know that any
Democrat would necessarily win in that situation
when Democrats have been in power. But I do think
that it's going to be an uphill battle.
Speaker 4: I appreciate that answer. Just
something I'm worried about. And yeah, I mean, I
guess my premise I wasn't totally certain whether
the George Floyd protests and the COVID 19
pandemic both contributed to Biden's win.
That was just kind of my understanding of what
happened that year. Yeah. Thank you very much.
Speaker 1: All right. My pleasure. There is
a Lincoln from Boston with an extraordinary
assessment, I would say, to some degree.